let's talk about some news and i want to
i want to start with dave chappelle
because
you know i was talking about the alec
baldwin incident earlier
uh i believe new information has emerged
showing that alec baldwin is is
potentially criminally responsible for
this and i'm not trying to make this a
segment about alec baldwin but i want to
explain
this is a guy
who is the producer in a movie
who knew there had been a neglig
negligent discharge multiple times
was then handed a weapon did not check
it even though he's been trained for
decades pointed it at the crew pulled
the trigger killing a woman
and you see all these people on the left
saying he's not at fault it was an
accident there was a post on reddit
where they were like if you think that a
guy who accidentally shot someone should
go to jail but the president shouldn't
you know donald trump then they're like
yeah something's wrong with you and i'm
like let me just say one more time
alec baldwin was a producer on the movie
there had been two separate negligent
discharges the crew knew about some
crude walked off the set he has been
trained in how to handle the firearms on
different movies and he didn't which
means there's gonna there's got to be a
criminal investigation into what he knew
and what he didn't now i bring that up
because it's purely cultural the
politics don't matter
alec baldwin is an activist right so
everyone's like oh you know alec baldwin
we've got to protect him that's really
what it's about so when i see this story
with dave chappelle not a tran to segue
into why why the dave chappelle story
matters i actually was saying in the
past week or so with this whole dave
chappelle netflix thing you get the
netflix employees coming out physically
attacking a guy claiming that after they
destroy his sign claim it's now a weapon
then the media reports that the guy was
actually the one attacking them
culture is everything and they've got
the media they've got cultural
institutions but dave chippell did
something funny variety says dave
chappelle willing to discuss the closer
with trans community but says he's not
bending to anybody's demands this is not
true dave chappelle actually says
members of the lgbtq plus and trans
community were supportive of him these
are the activists these are the wingnut
activists the political actors
not people who are simply lgbtq and he
said quote
i want everyone everyone in this
audience to know that even though the
media frames it that it's me versus that
community
that is not what it is do not blame the
lgbtq community for any of this crap
this is nothing to do with them it's
about corporate interests and what i can
say and what i cannot say for the record
and i need you to know this everyone i
know from that community has been loving
and supportive supporting so i don't
know what all this nonsense is about
he said i believe his uh chappelle also
spoke about the upcoming documentary
this film that i made was in uh was
invited to every film festival in the
united states and some of those
invitations i accepted when this
controversy came out about the closer
they began disinviting me from these
film festivals and now today not a film
company not a movie studio not a film
festival nobody will touch this film
thank god for ted sarandos and netflix
he's the only one that didn't cancel me
yet this is this is important context
people did not realize that dave
chappelle has been canceled across the
board but he's standing defiant
they going to say though chappelle said
he was willing to meet with some members
of the trans community
or the activist community see how they
try to do that with variety they try to
make make these these these extremists
the entirety of the trans community i'm
pretty sure blair white's a member of
that community we had a fan at the event
saturday who was trans this is not fair
he says he jokingly jokingly jokingly
listed off a slew of conditions that
would have to be met quote to the
transgender community i am more than
willing to give you an audience but you
will not summon me i'm not bending to
anybody's demands and if you want to
meet with me i'd be more than willing to
but i have some conditions first of all
you cannot come if you have not watched
my special from beginning to end nice
you must come to a place of my choosing
at a time of my choosing and thirdly you
must admit that hannah gadsby is not
funny
there was brilliant smart i loved it and
that was the perfect response we needed
right now there's a huge conflict
happening and we also have to understand
that this is not just dave chappelle
shooting shots for no reason this hannah
gatsby attacked dave and the ceo of
netflix before
the ceo of netflix came out in response
to a lot of this controversy by saying
quote so we have sex education orange is
the new black control z hannah gadsby
and dave chappelle all on netflix key to
this is increasing diversity on the
content team itself now that's a simple
response saying hey everyone here uh
gets a voice on this platform on this
very important platform and hannah
responded on instagram
by saying quote ted just a quick note to
let you know that i would prefer if you
didn't drag my name into your mess now i
have to deal with even more of the hate
and anger that dave chappelle's fans
like to unleash on me every time dave
gets 20 million dollars to process his
emotions stunned partial world views and
then later she adds you didn't pay me
nearly enough to deal with this with the
real world consequences of the hate
speech whistling you refuse to
acknowledge f you ted your and your
amoral algorithm cult so those are very
big words by her yeah
well i think a lot of people are angry
at uh gatsby for you know continuing the
marketing market what she does is comedy
i mean
that would induce some kind of hateful
response in me if i was told this was
going to be funny and i watched what she
did
uh but you know you've made a really
excellent point there though about how
they keep trying to say that this
activist fringe represents this wide
swath of people i saw andrew sullivan
speak just a couple of weeks ago and he
made this point where he said you know
it's been crazy you know i'm a gay man
you know my historical civil rights
struggle and whatever else there is
about my identity is not the same as a
lesbian it's not the same as a bisexual
it's not the same as a transsexual and
with q they're just including every
white woman with blue hair
um i mean i it's absolutely insane that
somehow you can claim to speak for so
many people and everyone just accept
that as a fact i'll say this i'll take
credit for being at least somewhat right
in this regard because i was saying when
it's starting i think dave chappelle is
going to lose this one i tweeted lol
they're trying to cancel dave chappelle
and i think it and i said actually i
think it might work
to hear dave come out and say that he's
being disinvited from film festivals and
no one will touch this film anymore they
got him
i yeah no i i i think you're right i'm
talking about the closer yeah i'm pretty
sure he's talking about the closer
oh closer the closer well
man no
netflix owns it it's licensed yeah but
he's saying he he says the film i made
was invited to every film festival in
the u.s
when the controversy came out he got
disinvited from all of these film
festivals it was only netflix that were
willing to take him i think this only
happened because he opened up that
possibility by ending the comedy special
seriously and i think if he would have
laughed it off i think it would have
been like sticks and stones that's just
my own personal opinion on this matter
but again as you see hannah gatsby
responds very seriously the best way to
disarm someone who's too serious and
taking themselves way too seriously is
to laugh at them so this was the perfect
response to hannah and and you know a
lot of people are laughing about this a
lot of people are talking about this
this is this is something that is could
go either way but uh the shots were
fired back by dave it was good to see
those shots fired so i also want to say
i think people make a mistake in
thinking that this is somehow about the
audience i mean this is really about
what's going on internally at all of
these entertainment companies
a couple months back i did a story on
digital advertising and how there are
all these boycotts against you know you
know right leaning media and stuff like
that and the guy who i talked to an
advertising exec and and he made this
point you know explicitly said it used
to be when this stuff first started
happening you go to the company and you
say look this is just a social media
focus it's going to blow over in 48
hours you've got nothing to worry about
now it's totally different the culture
has penetrated these companies so what
you've got to worry about is like you
know sarandos and netflix or whatever
dealing with his you know top 10 10 of
his top executives coming to him saying
you know i'm not going to work at this
company if you continue to act this way
because they're all look that's the
that's the firearm
yeah they got to fire these people well
they also have to deal with the esg and
a lot of the big banks and a lot of the
big institutions that are pushing
pressure on them so it's not just
netflix and the employees there i mean
and even with that protest i mean did
you see how the media hyped it up a
thousand people are going to come out
maybe a few dozen let's be honest here i
think that was actually fair uh so i saw
the criticism that there was like one
source that said uh we estimate a
thousand people will come the media ran
it and then everyone picked the story up
but as you know luke whenever you see a
a a social media post saying like come
to this event and there are invites
given up
on facebook when it says a thousand we
always would be like that means a
hundred yeah for sure because you get
ten times as many people saying they
will go and a tenth show up
but but this is also important to bring
up because they had the mainstream media
hyping this up so people were hearing
about this people knew about this far
and wide they were doing showed up
exactly i mean when you compare that you
we also have to understand that on the
bigger backdrop of it that they got a
lot of promotion for this and if you
have that much promotion you would
expect a bigger protest from my own
personal perspective but again that just
proves what i was saying this is not
about what audiences want out of comedy
this is about the imperatives of
corporations that's what this is about i
think that you know
dave chappelle is
it's like a grandfathering and kind of
thing where when dave chappelle's career
ends
when he gets old and moves on we will
never see a dave chappelle
for this this new time period so i'll
put it this way assuming that
you know what let me slow down
michael malus likes to say you know
these people are so dumb how could you
possibly think we're going to lose and
i'm like dude zombies are dumb too
but a lot of them overwhelm the system
and then people are running at least in
movies if dave chappelle is saying there
that festivals are canceling him and
he's the king
joe rogan said he's possibly the
funniest guy the funniest comedian in
the planet
then then what does that mean for where
we're headed so what happens now is you
know i was actually thinking that dave
chappelle might survive this he might
survive the cancellation to a certain
degree
and then what would happen is they would
just be like
let him age out once he's no longer in
media or relevant we just don't the next
generation do it so there was that guy
shane what's his name uh what the guy
from snl who was like he got fired yeah
i don't remember members last night
gillis
jane mcgillis
check that out so this is a really good
example shane gillis did an asian accent
stereotype you remember the story yeah i
do and then he got fired
uh chappelle on netflix did the same did
a even more egregious where he like made
the face and everything and it was
celebrated they cheered for it they even
gave him another special at you know 20
plus million dollars
so so i for a while i thought okay
they're going to not let any of the new
guys any new people with this kind of
humor edgy humor get jobs and they'll
tolerate the old comedians until they're
finally gone now it's like they're even
nuking chappelle now you know so i'm not
i'm not i don't want to be
i think people need to realize
if the story ended there fine i guess
you'd call that pessimistic but i'm not
saying the story ends there i'm saying
we're doing stuff we had an event with
ryan long i can't say what ryan long
said hilarious he's awesome but it was
insane everyone was like
ryan long is an amazing comedian and
then he was like he it was i don't i
can't spoil any of the jokes but it was
extremely offensive you had people going
like oh man but it was hilarious
and you're not going to find that on
netflix no you're not going to find that
but i do think things are happening like
so like vaclav havel in czechoslovakia
you know he wrote this famous essay
where he talked about the creation of a
parallel polis
meaning that you know when you live in a
culture that is so you know dominated by
lies that it's necessary for the people
that don't want to live too by those
lies to like create up you know their
own institutions in their own culture
and live by that now the crazy thing
about this what's happening is they're
foisting all this stuff on us from the
top down right but at the same time
we're not communist czechoslovakia you
know i mean you know maybe you know it's
not dark yet it's getting there but um
we still live in a culture where we can
build our own institutions we can do new
things like you know this show for
instance we can build up a parallel
polis and maybe if we do enough of that
then we can supplant this sort of you
know dominant ideology yeah definitely
especially with the way psychedelics
break people out of that crap i think
that and they're like in dc now they've
decriminalized psilocybin i think pretty
much uh washington state like that will
shatter this nonsense maybe there's a
lot of people who live in this matrix
you know but i want to say something i
want to say i i i was enlightened today
when my name was trending on twitter oh
and uh it was also trending alongside
noam chomsky
for one reason
dune
the new movie you saw it uh i saw half
of it
because we walked out of the theater
um i will say this and i'm trying to be
offensive so get ready to be offended
dune fans
the only people who like dune are the
originalists who are fans of the book
they understand what they're watching
and they're amazed and inspired by the
cinematography the art it was beautiful
the music was amazing incredible and
robots that were made to be on the
internet to prop up the movie and try
and help sell it but i genuinely think
they're trying to you know we talked
about this after we walked out i think i
think they're trying to tank the movie
because they released it for free on hbo
max and the theater was empty
but uh i'm i i was going to say you know
i'm trending on twitter and i'm like
this is why there's going to be a civil
war not seriously about dune but we
walked into the theater i said the movie
was too slow there was no story in the
hour we watched it was confusing and
nothing was happening to the hardcore
dude fans they totally understood it we
walked out but to see the amount of hate
that was generated by this
and a ton of the tweets were basically
like
they were political the the leftist dune
fans were attacking me over politics for
me saying i didn't enjoy a movie and i'm
like we are absolutely effed
if if if we're like at a point where
the these leftists are all sharing my
tweet my name was trending because
leftists were quoting me and sharing it
around i had high profile youtubers on
the left that was their big attack
that was it not not a policy position
because what what what what do i tweet
about where they're going to be like
something i disagree with
i look at things like that
which you know in turn like the alec
baldwin thing that's why i think culture
is the most important thing
otherwise or i should say
what's happening is that
there are there are people like noam
chomsky and we'll we'll start talking
about noam chomsky in a minute who think
that they own all culture the entire
country and that they are the dominant
force with supreme power
and then there are people who realize
that's not true and these people are
moral absolutist and authoritarians but
i wonder you know if people if any of
those people will will realize that they
don't have the majorities they think
they do
i think sometimes we might be too hard
on ourselves and i think we should
celebrate some victories especially when
it comes to alternatives whether it's
this show
rogan and others we have to understand
even with all the odds against us even
with the algorithms even with the
demonetizations the down rankings and
the controlling of the algorithms still
our voices are heard and i think that's
a victory in itself but even if they do
cancel dave at these festivals these
festivals are missing out on a real
discussion that people really want to
have about these issues that is honest
that isn't censored that isn't squeezy
cleaned that isn't people lecturing them
about what they think is right so i
think these voices will always be heard
in one way or another and it's it's a
good thing thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time